se llamaba alieza abkari tenía 61 años
exhibi viceministro de defensa fue
ejecutado en la orca su muerte fue
anunciada por televisión
fue condenado a muerte por corrupción y
por atentar contra la seguridad interior
y exterior del país mediante actividades
de espionaje Era uno de los agentes más
importantes de la inteligencia británica
proporcionaba información sobre el país
al servicio de espionaje del enemigo
a la vez pero la República islámica de
ira no reconoce la doble nacionalidad a
sus ciudadanos su ejecución fue
enérgicamente condenada en Londres el
Primer Ministro británico publicó estas
palabras
estoy consternado por la ejecución en
Irán del ciudadano británico iraní
alieza se trata de un acto insensible y
cobarde llevado por un régimen bárbaro
que no respeta los derechos humanos de
su propio pueblo mis pensamientos están
con los amigos y la familia de alieza la
ejecución de acbarie se produce en un
momento en que Irán se ve sacudido por
protestas desencadenadas por la muerte
en septiembre de masa a mini la joven
kurdayraní de 22 años había sido
detenida por la policía de la moral por
no llevar bien puesto el velo islámico
los tribunales iraníes han confirmado
las condenas a muerte de 18 personas en
relación con las protestas 4 de ellas ya
han sido ejecutadas Desatando una
indignación internacional